- I think that the risk of the Democrats
is they fall as out of touch with people,
living in the Midwest,
living wherever else it is
in this country.
Open-door immigration
got Brexit over the line
and has destroyed socialism
in the United Kingdom.
And that I think is a
very inspiring message.
But, it needs a Republican Party
that's got a distinct, clear message
as to how they're gonna
deal with the crisis.
So they've got to get
themselves organized.
But with the right message,
there are an awful lot of Democrat voters
that will vote Republican next year.
(slow tempo music)
- I'm Dave Rubin, and joining me today
is a British activist,
commentator, former leader
of the UK Independence Party,
as well as the former
leader of the Brexit Party.
And now he's on tour
right here in the US of A,
Nigel Farage.
I don't know how we
haven't done this before.
Finally, welcome to the The Rubin Report.
- Well, I'm delighted to be here,
and yeah, I've come actually
with a very optimistic message
because I know a lot of Conservatives here
are really down at the moment, you know,
down that their guy got 75 million votes
and somehow didn't win.
Down about what's going on in our cities
with a deliberate attempt to
divide black and white people,
which is horrendous,
and down about what Biden might do.
Is he gonna pack the court, or
I mean, all of these things.
And my sense from my American friends,
is some of them are down
to the point of being disillusioned.
- [Dave] Yeah.
- And disillusioned movements,
pessimistic movements don't win.
So the message I've come with is this.
We voted Brexit June 23rd,
2016, a great historic night.
Three years later, guess what?
Our contract, our contract
to leave on March 29th, 2019,
we woke up on March 30th.
Not only had we not left,
it looked like there was
no prospect of us leaving.
And yet, we led a grassroots
rebellion fight back.
We've smashed the establishment.
We've won.
We've got Brexit.
The Socialist Party in the UK,
who were heavily on the remain side,
and heavily pro open borders,
are literally being crushed
electorally week by week.
And my message is, however bad it looks,
actually this administration
are making some terrible mistakes.
What is happening on the border,
effectively, turns every
state into a border state.
So my message is, don't be down.
Don't be mad.
There's a big chance here for
a massive victory in 2022,
and an even bigger one in 2024.
But the right in America needs to unite,
needs to have some common messaging,
just one or two less egos around the place
might be quite helpful.
But don't-
Look, if we could beat
the global establishment
and get Brexit back over
the line, you can do it.
- So I love the message, obviously.
There's something kind of funny.
You're coming to America
to bring less ego.
That's a tough one, that's a tough one.
But one of the things
that I love about you,
and we've gotten to know each other
over the years a little bit.
We've had a couple of gin and
tonics together once or twice.
- We sure have, yep.
- But you're the type of
politician that actually does
instead of just talks.
Can you talk a little bit
about what that is like?
Because I think most people
see politicians at this point,
basically just as bureaucrats
who pretty much just take
their money and do nothing,
or maybe lock them in their homes.
But you actually make things happen,
and that's gotta be very
different than most of the people
that you're around often,
or have been around over the years.
- So in June '99, against the
flow, totally unpredicted,
I found myself being elected as a member
of the European parliament.
And everybody was shocked.
Yeah, who is this guy?
What's this new party?
And I remember the next
morning, the phone rang,
and it was a guy who'd been a commentator
and a satirist in Britain,
a guy called Christopher
Booker, very intelligent man.
And Christopher said to
me that morning, he said,
"Nigel, after 40 years
of study, I can tell you,
"there are two types
of people in politics.
"There are those who want to be someone,
"and there are those who
want to do something.
"And make your mind up young man."
I was young then.
He said, "Make your mind up young man,
"which of those you want to be?"
And here's the point.
He was absolutely right.
The vast majority of people
in politics are there
for rank, title, position, status.
And they'll do, I mean,
they'll sell their grandmothers
to climb the greasy pole,
because for them it's all
about career advancement.
Then you get people in
politics who are doing it
out of genuine conviction
because they believe the
agenda they're pursuing
is gonna make their country better,
and the lives of their people better.
And I personally couldn't
give a damn about titles.
People say, "oh, you know,
you're not Lord Nigel,
"you're not Sir Nigel."
I couldn't care less about any of that.
I did this because I could
see globalism building.
Back in the 1990s, I could see bureaucracy
was beginning to win over democracy,
and I was determined to
do something about it.
So yeah, I'm a doer, and
I'm not here for the fight.
- Do you remember when you first saw it?
When was the first moment
that you saw something
that really alarmed you?
- The first big moment was in 1990
when the government pegged Sterling
against the basket of European currencies.
Effectively, the Deutsche Mark.
Now, you know, anybody with
any economic history knows
all pegged currency
systems end in disaster.
None of them through time ever succeed.
And they'd done it because
they wanted us to join
what became the Euro.
And that was the first alarm bell,
that whatever they were
telling the electorate,
come general election time,
actually, they were literally
selling off our country.
And then there was a rebellion.
In 1993, there was a rebellion.
Backbench Conservatives rebelled
over a new European treaty.
The treaty that turned it
from an European community
into a European union
with a flag, and anthem,
and all of those things.
And I watched this rebellion.
And right at the last minute, John Major,
who was the Prime Minister,
used a motion of confidence
to get this treaty pushed through.
And I couldn't believe it.
Well, hang on.
You've been telling me guys
that if this treaty goes through,
we lose our independence.
And yet when it came to it,
you decided to put your career,
you decided to put your party
above the interests of the country.
And I realized then that the
so-called Tory Euroskeptics
were frankly a bunch of chinless
wonders, a bunch of losers.
None of them have a stomach for the fight.
And I said in '93, "I'm gonna do this.
"I don't care if people laugh at me.
"I don't care if I'm the only
person that votes for me.
"I'm gonna fight this and do
this as a matter of principle."
And you know, frankly,
that moment that spelt the
next 27 years of my life.
- Did you have any idea the opposition
that you were gonna come against?
I mean, when I was in London last time,
when I saw you it was during
the tour with Jordan Peterson,
and it was in the middle of Brexit,
but there was still a huge feeling like,
ah, maybe it's not gonna happen,
and maybe the bureaucrats
still will take over
or do some last minute tricks.
And then of course it was framed
that all the people that
supported it were racists,
and bigots, and all the rest of it.
But just the endless
machine that we now all see
that has been so exposed.
And in many ways, from
an American perspective,
thanks to Donald Trump was so exposed.
Did you realize how crazy
that machine was gonna be,
and what it was gonna do
to you and your supporters?
- Gandhi, of course, fought
the campaign for India
to leave the British empire
and to get his independence.
And Gandhi once said,
"First they ignore you.
"Then they laugh at you.
"Then they attack you.
"And then you win."
And I went through every
one of those four stages.
You know, in the beginning I
was being ignored completely.
When they couldn't ignore me,
I think I was the most cartooned,
the most lampooned person on comedy shows.
It was as if, I was like
the sort of patron saint
of lost causes.
And then, and then the
moment that it really changed
was in 2004, eight, and then
10 former communist countries
joined the European Union
with total rights of free movement.
And this led to millions of people
coming into the United Kingdom.
It was too much, too quickly.
It was out of control.
And that was the moment when
I linked the immigration issue
with the sovereignty issue,
the independence issue.
And that was the moment that
the establishment turned on me,
and they spent basically the next 15 years
trying to tell anyone that would listen,
that I was a racist leading
a dark dangerous movement
that harked back to the 1930s.
I mean, nothing could have been, David,
nothing could have been
further from the truth.
That is what they tried to do.
And I have to tell you, in all honesty,
if I had known just how
horrible my life was gonna be,
I don't know whether I would have done it.
I mean, you know, I finished up
having to live with
protection round the clock.
If you went out somewhere,
people threw things at you.
And this was the media,
this was mainstream media
working with big global corporations
trying to maintain
their own self-interest.
But in the end, in the end, you know,
you can keep pushing
accusations against somebody,
but if you can't prove it,
it's a little bit like crying wolf.
And in the end, people saw through it.
But yeah, it was tough, it was hard.
And then, you know, I was
perhaps guilty of some naivety.
Because on the 23rd of June, 2016,
that moment where we've won,
and all the parties promised
that they would honor the result.
And then we saw a three-year campaign.
As you say, we were told we
didn't know what we voted for.
We were told property
prices would collapse.
We were told millions
of jobs would be lost.
We were told foreign direct investment
from America and elsewhere would dry up.
We were even told, brace
yourself for this one,
we even told there would be an outbreak
of super gonorrhea in the country
because the drug that was used to treat it
came from Germany,
and we wouldn't even
get supplies of drugs.
I mean, there is no depth
to which these people did not sing.
But the resolve of the British people
did not budge one inch.
And I believe there is a parallel.
I don't believe those 75 million people
who voted for Donald Trump
have changed their mind.
If I think in many ways,
probably in their hearts
they feel it even more strongly.
And that's why I'm on this
tour, to spread that message,
a message of optimism, a message
that you can beat the odds,
you really can.
- I know you're a pro,
because you just did the exact
transition I was going for,
because there are so many parallels
to what's happening in America right now.
And everything that you just described
that the UK has been going
through for, you know,
really the last 20 years.
Are you sort of surprised that America,
that Conservatives, or
right-leaning people,
or anyone that cares about that flag
that's right behind you,
that everyone seems a
little bit lost right now,
that there really is a
shell shock situation since,
really, I think it started
probably on January 6th,
but then once Biden took over,
and that he's been so
much further to the left
than most people thought.
Not that I thought, but that, you know,
the pundit class thought.
- Yeah look, I think, yeah,
obviously the election result was a shock.
The events of January
the 6th were unsavory.
There's no other way of putting it.
And it's been difficult.
It's been very, very difficult.
And yes, as you say, Biden
being pulled to the left,
Biden, you know, even
dropping references to God,
which I think shocked--
- Just this morning, yeah.
- Many, many, yeah, yeah.
Many, many tens of millions of Americans.
I understand why people
feel depressed and down.
But look, I was getting this
in 2018 in the UK, into 2019.
Everyone saying to me, "Nigel,
it's done, it's finished,
"it's not gonna happen."
And I kept saying to them, "No".
And I spent that period of time planning,
planning the next fight back,
planning my next big campaign,
because I knew, I just knew
that once we got the arguments
back out there again,
people would rally, rally
to the flag as it were.
So look, I understand it,
but I think there is a responsibility here
on American commentators,
American journalists,
American politicians who are on the center
right in this country.
They have a responsibility
to stop do-mongering,
frankly, to the extent
that many of them are.
And over course of the
last couple of weeks,
I've met with a lot of
Congressmen, Congresswomen.
And they are down.
You know, they are
depressed, they are down.
Well if you're depressed and down,
if you're disillusioned,
if you're defeatist,
that then becomes a
self-fulfilling prophecy.
So I would just say to
all these commentators
and all these elected politicians,
you know, if you give the appearance
of being miserable and depressed,
you are letting down not just your party,
not just the millions of voters,
you're letting down the country.
I mean, goodness me.
You know, Winston Churchill
in the middle of the blitz
when the big cities were being bombed
night after night for 60 nights,
and what did Churchill do?
He said, "We will come
through this and move on
"to the sunlit uplands."
Even at that darkest of desperate moments
with thousands being
killed everyday by bombing,
Churchill offered a vision,
the shining light on
the hill, the optimism.
And that's what needs,
Conservative politicians
need to start doing it.
And frankly, need to start
doing it very quickly
because the electoral cycles here,
well, it's almost unending, isn't it?
But if you know, if there
are gonna be big successes
in the midterms, dramatic
successes in the midterms,
people have gotta get prepared
and start planning right now.
- When you decided to do this tour,
were you sorta like, oh man,
I can't believe that the US,
that I'm gonna have to come to the US
to give a little jolt to this thing?
I mean, where's the me
at the moment you know,
as Trump is still somewhat on the outside.
- Yeah look, my first job after
I left college was in 1982
working for Drexel Burnham
Lambert of Wall Street fame,
all right?
I spent 20 years working
for American companies
before getting involved in politics.
And since 2016, I've been pretty involved
in politics here too.
You know, I came in 2016,
Trump put me on a stage with
him in Jackson, Mississippi,
and I came with the message
that because we'd won Brexit
against the establishment,
that you too, the Trump
campaign, could upset the odds.
So I have a huge interest
in what happens here.
I'd also say this to you.
You know, we've got Brexit, we're free.
We're away from this bureaucracy.
And the signs for the
future of our country
are looking very, very good.
Even the IMF Now thing,
having told us doom and
disaster would befall us.
But we're now gonna outperform
the French and German
economies, all right?
But you know, the point is
this, the point is this.
If we with Brexit, if America falls,
if America falls to hard left socialism,
you know, and we know that those behind
Black Lives Matter and
elsewhere are dedicated Marxists
determined to bring
down the Western world,
if America falls,
where does that leave
us as Brexit Britain?
Because the fact is,
the English speaking peoples of the world
share something extraordinary between us.
You know, we are all family.
You know, whether people like that or not,
but we are all family.
So I don't want America to fall.
And I like to think, David,
that the message I brought in 2016
did give people a sense of,
"Wow, these guys have done it.
"We can do it."
And I'm trying to come back
with that same optimistic message again.
So I'm spending six weeks going round,
you know, speaking to grassroots events,
trying to rally people.
And I can tell you already two weeks in,
the number of people that
have come up to me and said,
"Boy, I really needed to hear that.
"I really needed something positive."
So I hope, I hope I can do a bit of good.
- You know, it's interesting.
The kid, I don't know if you
know the phrase "black pill",
but the kids are calling this black pill,
when your sort of your red pill
meaning you've woken up to all of this,
and then I know you get that one,
but then the black pill is,
oh, but now the whole system
is so corrupt and so against us
that you just sort of check out.
So you're kind of, you're kind
of waking them up from that
because that's the path you
don't want everybody to go down.
That's what I'm trying to do as well.
- Yeah, I mean, the
thing about Brexit was,
you know, it was a long campaign.
It took 27 years of my life.
But the thing that I
was able to do, David,
was to build a grassroots army.
A grassroots army which I
dubbed, "The People's Army".
And they were proud to
serve in The People's Army,
proud to give of their time,
their money, their love.
And it doesn't matter how
young you are, how old you are.
If you want to get involved,
you can all do something.
You can put things through doors,
you can make telephone calls.
And that's why freedom works.
You know, which is a non-party affiliated
grassroots conservative organization.
For me, that's the perfect fit.
And you know, all these men and women
who are gonna be running next year,
you know for seats,
they need, they need
their own People's Army.
And so that's what I'm trying to do.
And as I say, thus far,
I think I'm making,
you know, it may not be huge,
but I feel I can make
a bit of a difference.
- So I think people get the Brexit analogy
to the American experience.
Can you talk a little
bit about what happened
to the left in the UK as well
because your Labor Party really
went bananas under Corbyn,
and sort of became what
is so obvious to me
is becoming right now,
is happening right now
to our Democratic Party.
- So the British Labor Party,
you know, has its roots way back to 1900.
You know, it was a working class movement.
It was quite strongly Methodist
as well, sort of low church.
High church for the Tories,
low church for Labor
was kind of how it was.
And it was genuinely a
working class movement.
But a patriotic working class movement.
The Labor Party, you know,
whatever socialist policies
they brought in post 1945,
they believed in the country.
You know, Clement Attlee
who was the Prime Minister
that brought in the welfare state,
on his door, it said
"Major Clement Attlee."
He was proud of the first World
War service that he'd given.
And what has happened to the Labor Party,
is it's become a party of the
globalist metropolitan elite.
It's become a party predominantly
of the upper middle classes,
people born into relative
sort of champagne socialists, I guess,
is the kind of phrase that we would use.
And their globalist view
means they're ashamed
of saying anything vaguely patriotic.
They wouldn't be seen dead, you know,
with a Union Jack, or an
English Cross of Saint George,
'cause they don't like
any of this symbolism.
And on Brexit, they have
completely and utterly,
you know, turned their back
on Brexit in every way.
They lost a special election,
a by-election in the North of England.
It had been a Labor seat forever.
They pick someone to stand
who thinks we should
rejoin the European Union.
I mean, they just don't get it.
But the key, and this is
where I think the crossover
could be very interesting.
The key is this.
When UKIP started to pick
up millions of votes,
it wasn't just middle-class Conservatives
voted for Nigel Farage.
No, it was patriotic working class people
living in the North of England.
A lot of them in the North of England.
And people who believed that
mass uncontrolled immigration
was driving down their wages,
changing their communities
beyond all recognition.
And that doesn't make these people racist.
It makes them want to keep
their towns, their communities,
their families in some
shape that is recognizable.
And they were the people that came to me.
And you know, I'll tell you something.
The Labor Party at the center,
basically thinks we're
all global citizens.
We can all go wherever they want.
So Labor has lost its voters on Brexit.
It's lost its voters on open borders.
It's scared its voters when Jeremy Corbyn,
who was pretty much an anti-Semite
as well, was its leader.
And the Labor vote now is collapsing.
So look at what's happening on the border.
You know, I'll bet you if we
had dinner tonight with AOC,
now that sounds pretty
unlikely, David, I know.
- Probably not happening.
- But yeah, probably not happening.
But if we talked to that group,
they would not be in
the least bit concerned
about what's happening down on the border.
In fact, we understand some
of the people that come
are given Kamala Harris books to read.
I mean, you can't believe
it, but it's happening.
They don't think it matters.
And I think that the
risk for the Democrats
is they fall as out of touch with people
living in the Midwest,
living wherever else
it is in this country.
Open door immigration
got Brexit over the line,
and has destroyed socialism
in the United Kingdom.
And that I think is a
very inspiring message,
but it needs a Republican Party
that's got a distinct, clear message
as to how they're gonna
deal with the crisis.
So they've got to get
themselves organized.
But with the right message,
there are an awful lot of Democrat voters
that will vote Republican next year.
- Do you think there's
a fundamental reason
that the left tends to always
double down instead of saying,
"Oh, something has changed here,
"and maybe we need to take
a look in the mirror."
But they instead they always seem to go
to their most extreme.
- Well, I think you have to understand
who's driving the left.
You know, and frankly, follow
the money is very good advice
for most things in life.
And you know, if you look
at the kind of causes
that was Sorress's and others back,
you know, they are not
gonna change their view
one little bit.
These are big powerful organizations
that effectively wants us to finish up
with one world government
and one world people.
It's an updated form of
the old Marxist theory.
It's never ever worked.
It never ever will work.
And frankly, I think the elected
politicians, in most cases,
aren't much more than pawns in that game.
They are being used.
They are being directed.
They're not thinking freely.
And so all the influences
on them tell them,
no, don't worry.
Even if there is some
short term difficulty,
because you're doing the right thing.
And for them, of course,
the right thing, you know,
the kick they get is they
feel morally superior.
They actually think they're
better people than we are.
But none of that works when you go out
to a good ordinary decent
folk who work hard,
bring up their families, and you know,
Reagan was very good at this,
very good at getting
Democrats to vote Republican.
Trump has been very good.
And there is a kind of
a realignment I think,
going on within American politics.
And I think the opportunity
that it provides for 2022
is simply enormous.
- Where do you think Trump fits into that
because that seems to be
the outlier at the moment.
It's like, is he gonna run?
Does he, you know, what I've
been trying to tell people,
is to me, it seems like
the best thing he could do
is basically be the
outsider taking the fire.
And then you get a guy like DeSantis
to just run right through.
That seems to make sense to me.
But you know, Trump
obviously does whatever
Trump thinks is best.
- Yeah, I have spent some
time with him on this trip,
and that's a meeting of friends basically.
And we have become friends.
I said, this is what I said to him, okay?
And you know, I won't say what he said,
but this is what I said to him.
I said, "Look, we've
got the external threat
"of the Chinese Communist Party
"getting more and more aggressive."
And who's to say in Taiwan
or elsewhere what might occur
over the course of the next few years.
We've got the internal threat,
which of course is cancel culture
and the threats that represents
the free speech and everything else.
And I said to him, "I don't see anybody
"who's got the courage or the charisma
"to fight those things."
"Now, if somebody else comes along,
"who's got the big charisma
that can do the job,
"that can rally people in
those working class communities
"to go out and maybe for the
first time, vote Republican,
"if that person comes along then fine."
But you know something?
Donald Trump, people like him
don't come along very often.
I mean, the guy has got an
incredible animal magnetism,
and he's shown more courage as a leader
than any global leader
I've seen in my lifetime.
That guy was under relentless
assault from day one,
just as they tried to stop Brexit,
they tried to de-legitimized him.
You know, and it never stopped.
And of course, even if
eased back on his policies,
they would have eased back on
the pressure, but he didn't.
He's got the courage of a lion.
Now look, he's got his faults.
Of course he has.
We've all got our faults.
But you know, in his heart,
and with his instincts,
does he stand for the right things?
I truly believe that he does.
So you know, let's see
what happens, you know,
as the next couple of years roll out.
But you know what?
When I saw him, he's lost a lot of weight.
He's playing loads of golf,
taking loads of exercise.
He looks younger than he looked in 2016.
I mean, most American Presidents age.
Obama and co, we'll see them
graying before your eyes.
And the fact that he's gonna
be 78 next time around,
well, who knows.
But God willing, if he's
in the same kind of shape
that he's in now,
there's nothing to stop him from doing it.
And the other point here
that's worth mentioning,
I went to, I think it
was eight of the rallies
and the run-up to the November
election all over America.
I want to tell you something.
I've never seen enthusiasm.
- No, I know, I know.
- I've never ever seen anything like it.
They admire this man, they love this man.
And I would say to, you know,
those in a position of
power within the party,
if you really think you can
find someone better than this,
well, good luck to you.
- You know, it's kind of funny
because I remember when I met
you for breakfast one morning
and we took a picture
and I posted the picture,
and then people were saying,
"Oh look, you're with that racist.
"That racist."
And meanwhile, we sat there for two hours,
we talked about freedom,
we talk about liberty, all this stuff.
And it's very similar to
going to a Trump rally
when I started going to those
rallies, and I'm thinking,
"Oh, am I going to see these racists here
"or something like that?"
And it's the happiest, most joyful people,
who in many cases are
not political at all.
They're just there because
they want to express
some level of freedom.
Something like that.
- Yeah no, absolutely.
I mean, this has been a
constant attempt for the left
to tarnish us with this racism word,
and it just doesn't work anymore.
The real racists are actually those
behind Black Lives Matter.
I really mean that.
And I really mean that.
You know, when Martin Luther King said
in that amazing speech,
and I mean, what an orator the guy was.
But when he said, "I want my
four children to be judged,
"not for the color of their skin,
"but by the content of their character."
And now what's happening
through BLM and elsewhere,
is we are dividing people
up into different groups,
dividing them up on the grounds
of race, ethnicity, gender,
whatever else it may be.
And that is disastrous.
That is destructive.
That is the real racism.
And I loathe it.
I wanna live in a country where everybody
is treated exactly the same.
'Cause if you start
giving special privileges
to certain groups,
you then automatically
alienate other groups,
who feel left out.
A free, fair society would
have equality of opportunity
for all.
And of course, I condemn
and loathe racism.
And yes, there are some,
there is a fringe on the extreme right,
who I think we should simply,
they would have nothing
to do with whatsoever.
But you're quite right.
You know, whether it
was my UKIP supporters,
my Brexit Party supporters,
Trump supporters at the rallies,
these are very, very good decent people.
And the more mainstream
media, or Hillary Clinton
pointing fingers at them and call them
deplorable, or ignorant, or stupid,
the greater their resolve to fight back.
- What do you make about
how the BLM movement,
some of the Antifa stuff that,
now that is being exported.
I mean, you guys are seeing some of that
on the streets of London now,
and it's happening in other
Western countries as well.
- You know, mean within 24 hours
of the death of George Floyd,
within 24 hours, there were
riots in the streets of London.
So don't tell me this was
a spontaneous outpouring.
This was all planned.
They'd been waiting for the opportunity.
And I was disgusted.
I mean, to see the Cenotaph in London,
the monument to one
and a half million dead
fighting for liberty in two World Wars,
to see that desecrated.
To see the Churchill statue
repeatedly desecrated.
And what stunned me was to
see British police officers
taking the knee in the streets.
- And your police officers,
your police officers don't even have guns.
- They don't, well, some do, some do.
Some do, but I think we're gonna have to,
that's a policy that will need to change,
no question about that.
But to take the knee,
and I was going on UK TV,
and radio, and writing,
saying to everybody,
"Understand what this is."
If this organization was
genuinely about equality,
genuinely about getting
rid of racial prejudice,
I'd have no problem with it whatsoever.
But the truth of it is,
and you've only gotta read their website.
They tell you, they're in a
validly Marxist organization,
intent on defunding the police,
bringing down Western capitalism,
and renew Marxist order to take its place.
That is what they're doing.
They are trying to destroy us.
And yet I've been horrified
on both sides of the pond
to see big corporations,
you know, trying to say
wonderful things about them.
I even saw St John's Church
opposite the White House.
I was there yesterday.
And they've got a Black
Lives Matter poster.
What is going on?
Don't people realize this is
a bad, dangerous organization?
So you know, these are
things that really grieve me,
and it's the lack of courage
of enough people to stand up
and tell the truth for fear
of being called racist.
- So with that all in mind,
what do you think's gonna
happen with this mayoral race
in London?
'Cause it looks a little
messy at the moment.
- Well, one of the things
that has changed politics
in the United Kingdom
has been postal voting,
early mail-out voting.
We've seen it abused again,
and again, and again.
There is no country in which this is safe.
And I was trying to warn
America this time last year
that if you went down this route,
you know, the left will
always win at this.
'Cause you see, if you think
you're morally superior,
cheating is quite an easy thing to do.
Whereas our side, just,
our side won't cheat.
And I'm pleased to say that really,
but you're never gonna win.
The one country that's
got this right is France.
Now the French, the French
don't get much right
in my opinion,
but the one thing they've got right,
they've seen how open
postal voting is to fraud,
intimidation, and abuse, and
they've banned it completely.
So do you know what they do in France?
If you wanna vote in France,
I'll tell you what happens.
You go along to the local hall,
you show your identification,
you're given a piece of paper,
you go into a polling booth in secrecy,
you put a cross next to the
candidate or party you prefer.
And after that, there are
no voting machines used.
There's no need for those.
They're manually counted.
They're put in piles and totaled up.
And that is free and open democracy.
There's a big lesson we can learn from it.
Now what Carter's has got
going for him in London,
is they've signed up vast
numbers of the Muslim population
to these postal votes.
And I, look, I know that
in those communities,
you know, the women are
signed up for postal votes,
but do you actually think
they ever, ever, ever get
the chance to exercise that?
Of course they don't.
I once saw, I once saw a box,
a vote box being emptied
onto a table at a count
in a place called Oldham
in the North of England.
And unbelievably, of the
thousand or so ballots
that were in that box,
the percentage that were
voting for Labor was 100.
That is literally impossible.
So you know, that is
what keeping Sadiq Khan
holding on in London is the
power of that postal vote.
But even in London,
which has been the great Labor stronghold,
even there, the party is now seriously--
- What do you think of
my friend Lawrence Fox?
Do you think he has a chance to actually,
from a liberal, a true
liberal perspective,
do you think he has a chance to fight off
the progressive movement onslaught?
- Look, I admire
Lawrence, I like Lawrence.
I mean, you know, he's a great guy.
And the next time you're in
London, we'll go out together.
You know, he is a great guy to be with.
Starting new political
movements from scratch.
- You know a little something about this.
- I mean, it's done, you know,
it took me so many years
to get UKIP set up.
And in the end, we had 400
chapters around the country,
millions of supporters, but
it doesn't happen overnight.
Now the things that
Lawrence is battling for
are fundamentally important issues.
You know, it is about the relationship
between the individual and the state.
And this is something that we've
always prided ourselves on.
You know, frankly ever since Magna Casa.
But going all through the years,
we've been the freest of
all European countries.
In fact, the freest of all
the English speaking world.
We've never had to have ID
cards, or any of these things.
Now with COVID, we've seen
those liberties stripped away
in the most remarkable
and very hasty fashion.
So look, Lawrence, in terms
of making the arguments,
he's in the right place.
I wish him well.
But if I'm being honest with you,
it's gonna take a lot of
years to build a movement
that's big enough to--
- Do you make a distinction at this point
between someone that would say
they're an old school
liberal and a conservative.
Does that even, is there any
distinction worth mentioning
at this point?
- Well I mean, it's a
funny thing, isn't it?
You know, I mean, if you'd
said to me 20 years ago,
"Nigel, where are you on
the left-right spectrum?"
I'd have called myself
a Gladstonian liberal.
You know, Gladstone was
a liberal Prime Minister
back in the back of the 19th century,
but one who believed in
freedom of the individual,
you know, believed in the country.
- A JFK Democrat from our
perspective, basically.
- Yeah, yeah.
I have to say, I've
stopped using the word.
- Yeah, I get it.
- You know, classical liberalism.
You know, if you go to the Oxford Union,
you know, and debate with
some of the brightest students
in the world,
maybe there, you can talk
about classical liberalism.
If you try and talk about
classical liberalism
to anybody else, they sort of,
if they're Conservatives just go blah,
because the word "liberal",
now means illiberal.
The liberals wanna ban everything,
the liberals wanna control everything.
The liberals don't even
believe in free speech.
So yeah, classical liberalism I'm afraid
is only for the debating changes.
- I get it, I wrote a book defending it,
but I hear ya, I hear ya.
You mentioned the lockdowns.
You've had some difference of opinion
with Boris Johnson on this.
Where are you guys at
with lockdowns right now?
Is it vastly different in the
cities versus the suburbs?
- Well, the truth of it is,
that Boris Johnson's
government were painfully slow
to address the issue
when it first came to us.
You know, 18 million people
flew into the United Kingdom
during the first months of COVID-19
without a single person even
being asked to take a test.
You know, so we directly imported this.
When the government then did decide
it was gonna do something,
and lock us down,
the truth of it is, they've
taken it way too far.
At the moment, we're
50% locked down still.
I mean, even though COVID deaths now
are in single figures every day, right?
Single figures every day.
On many days, the number of
road deaths will be bigger
than the number of COVID deaths.
And suicides on a lot
of days will be bigger
than COVID deaths.
You can go to a pub, but
you can't drink inside.
You have to drink outside,
which at this time of the year in England,
isn't very appealing.
You can go to a restaurant,
but you can't eat inside,
you have to eat outside.
Non-essential shops are back open,
but the damage that's been
done to them by Amazon
is just incalculable,
because that's where we
finished up with this.
You know, I couldn't go,
say I wanted to buy a pair
of trainers for my kids.
I couldn't go to the local
market town and buy them
because the shop was closed.
I had to order them through Amazon online.
And this is one of the great sadnesses.
It's the little people that have been so,
it's the self-employed and little people
that have been hurt.
And of course, the public
sector, oh, they love it.
I mean, this is fantastic for them.
They're being paid to sit
at home and drink beer
without any threat to their jobs.
So it's big business and big government
has benefited from this.
So look, frankly, we should
have eased up a long time ago.
But I will say this.
Boris, despite everything,
and despite his own personal difficulties,
of which he's got many.
I mean, it really is,
I mean, none of us have
ever lived perfect lives,
but gosh, his is very, very
complicated to say the least.
Despite all of that, there's
been one huge success,
and it's this.
It's the vaccine rollout, okay?
So as members of the European Union,
we were part of the
European Medicines Agency.
And the European Medicines Agency,
through an unelected
European commissioner,
was to make the decision in any pandemic
as to what should be done.
We left the European
Medicines Agency with Brexit,
and The Guardian and others said,
this proved that Brexit was a death cult,
because we'd left the all embracing arms
of this big unelected government.
And the truth of it is,
the one thing they have
got spectacularly right,
they handed this job to a
woman from private equity,
who in six months, put in place a system,
as opposed to the EU,
where a woman from Cyprus
who nobody had ever heard of,
who nobody ever voted for,
with a degree in psychology
and no other life achievements
that I could discern,
has made an absolute complete
and utter mess of it.
So you know, basically
we've vaccinated you know,
three, four, five times
the number of people
that our European counterparts have,
and that is being seen as, you know,
by the way, if you don't
wanna take the vaccine,
nobody should force you
to take the vaccine,
but basically, people over
50, people who are overweight,
people who've got diabetes,
you know, in vast numbers,
they have gone to get the vaccine,
and it kind of proves, whether
you're pro-vaccine or not,
it kind of proves that we're better off
outside the European Union,
we're better off making our own decisions.
And the approval rating
for Brexit is now 70%.
- I saw that this morning.
- 70%.
- I mean, that's actually incredible.
So to you, that must be like
the true reward of this thing
that when push came to shove,
not only did you get it there,
but then in the, you
know, year or so since,
people are actually going,
"Oh, there was a reason for this,
"and the country didn't collapse,
"and racists aren't running in the streets
"and everything else."
- Yeah.
David, I could not be happier.
You know, how many people,
how many people set out
with a massive life ambition
and actually achieve it?
And I have.
I mean frankly, I almost
can't believe my luck.
I mean now.
- It's not luck.
- Well, there's always a bit of luck.
But now, I can go to
the local supermarket,
and walk around and get some shopping
without a security guard,
and people are coming up and saying,
"Well done, Nige.
"We love it."
So things have changed a little bit.
I mean, you know, all
that abuse that I took
for year, after year, after year,
you know, the game has changed, we're out.
In terms of geo politics,
Brexit is the biggest change
since the fall of the Berlin
Wall over 30 years ago.
It's the first, you know,
literally the first big kickback
against globalism,
and I'm optimistic that other
European countries in time,
will follow us too.
- So speaking of other European countries,
do you sense that some of the
Eastern European countries
that are doing more on borders right now
that seem to be fighting
a lot of the critical race theory stuff,
not allowing some of the
gender stuff into the system,
do you sense that they're better
set up to fight this stuff
than say the UK and America,
because they were communist
countries and more recently,
and they sorta get the bad stuff
that could be on the horizon.
Is that really why
they're setting up well?
I'm talking specifically about Poland
and some of the countries over there.
- Yeah.
I mean, have a five minute study
of the history of Poland
in the 20th century.
It is a desperate, desperate history.
You know, I mean, not just
communist, but Nazis invaded,
I mean, the whole thing.
So bloody, so awful.
And of course, the tragedy
in 1945 that, you know,
as Churchill very much predicted
in that speech at Fulton
that we finished up with an
Iron Curtain, as he named it,
down the center of Europe.
You know, these Poles,
the reason they joined the European Union
is because it was sold
in a job lot with NATO.
Now, if I was a Pole, I would
absolutely want to be in NATO,
you know, for every reason.
But now the debate that's going
on in Poland and in Hungary,
is if unelected bureaucrats
in Brussels are telling us
who we should appoint to court positions,
what decisions we should make
on gay marriage or other,
you know, very important social issues,
the argument's now resurfacing,
well hey, what's the
difference between this
and living under the Soviet Union?
And you're right about their
culture, their identity,
and indeed their Christianity.
Christianity is very, very strong
in those two countries
that I've mentioned.
And I think everything
the European Union does
continues to alienate
those very proud countries.
And I think at some point, at some point,
they will not stay part of this Union.
And the other interesting
dynamic that's going on,
is the single European
currency, the Euro, all right,
means that all countries in it
are in the same economic
and monetary union.
How can Greece and Germany co-exist
inside the same economic
amount of treatment?
They can't.
It's literally impossible
for cultural reasons.
And at some point in time, Greece, Italy,
perhaps even Portugal will decide,
we simply can't go on like this,
because you know,
they've got the wrong
valuation of currency.
It's hopeless.
And I remember the late
great Milton Friedman saying,
that if you get stuck in a currency peg
that's wrong for your country,
one of two things happens.
Either you get out and de-value,
or you de-value the country.
And you know something--
- I think Greece knows
a little something about that right now.
- Well, since 2009, Greek
GDP is over 25% down.
And Americans think about that.
You know, buddy, can you spare us a dime?
In the Depression, was a 16% fall.
This is a 25% fall.
So you know, far from being
this wonderful project
that was gonna serve all
the peoples of Europe well,
it's robbing them of their independence,
it's making huge numbers of them poorer.
Oh sure, if I was a German
car manufacturer, I'd love it
because the Deutsche Mark
would be a sight higher
than the Euro is, so it's been
wonderful for German exports.
But no, look, I recognized this early on.
I recognized that this was
just yet another attempt
to dominate everything
and take everything over.
I called it in the parliament repeatedly.
I said, this is the new form of communism.
And of course, whenever I did that,
500 of them would start booing,
and screaming, and jeering.
But hey, it didn't bother me.
I mean, I rather enjoyed it.
And that's what it is.
And of course, for the globalists,
you know, for people here
like the Clintons, the Bidens, the Obamas
who so loved the European Union project,
Brussels is the epicenter
of the globalist project.
And if we can defeat that,
I really genuinely believe
we're taking the free world,
or putting the free world back
into a far better place.
- Who do you think is
behind the Biden thing?
I mean well, do you think it's Biden
that's behind the Biden thing?
That seems to be the question people say,
okay, is it the Clinton machine behind it?
Is it the Obama machine?
Is there a distinction?
But like, who do you think
is really kind of driving this thing?
- Well it can't be him obviously.
I mean, you know, look, he's
just a duffer, isn't he?
I mean, he can barely
string a sentence together.
And so he's quite malleable.
And for some of those
with a hard left agenda,
that makes him quite useful
because he isn't gonna resist too much.
I'm also told that his actual work rate,
and it's down to just
less than a handful of hours every day.
He's just physically not up to it.
And I've been asking him the
same question that you've asked
in the last two weeks here.
The common consensus is that Team Obama
still have a massive hand
to play in all of this.
And I don't know enough, maybe you do.
I don't know enough to contradict this,
but that certainly from
those who I would judge
to be in the know, that's the argument.
- You remember there was that
famous interview years ago
where Obama said it would be great
if he could just not be President,
but be pulling the strings from behind.
That would be pretty, I mean,
the guy said it himself.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Well, I think to some degree,
that does appear to be happening, yeah.
- Do you sense now that
you're here in America,
and you're on tour and you're
in the middle of the country,
and seeing the heartland and everything,
that America is uniquely
set up to fight this,
even though maybe we
can't see it right now,
but our history, the
way we left King George,
the way we fought for
independence in a very unique way,
the way that this country was set up
as an idea for all people.
Is that in essence the thing
that you really wanna reignite,
and is that why you've got
that flag behind you right now?
- Yes.
Yes, yeah, you know, I
mean I'm not American,
but I have a huge, as I've
said already in this interview,
a huge self-interest,
and I care passionately what
happens in this country.
And you're right, you know,
when American children were
being taught properly at school,
I'm not sure they all are these days,
but they were being taught
all about the revolution,
breaking free, about liberty,
about the amazing constitution
that those brilliant minds put together.
So yeah, I think it is deeply ingrained
within the American people.
Of course, you know through
welfarism and other problems,
you know, there is a growth
of the leftist ideology,
but it is still a small activist minority.
And what you've gotta do is to reach out.
You know, there's something like 30, 40%,
40% who just don't vote
in American elections.
And yet their lives are
being directly affected
by what has happened.
We got Brexit.
We got Brexit, we won that referendum
because two and a half million people
who literally never voted
in their lives came out
because they believed they
can make a difference.
And I think if the Republican candidates
can get that message out,
and it's not just the negative message,
but it is genuinely about how
they could make life better for people.
You've gotta mobilize those
that don't normally vote.
And I think America's history
does lend itself to that,
yes, I do.
- Yeah, can you, we're
gonna link obviously
to the tour down below,
but what are you doing?
What are you actually doing on the tour?
I mean, are you just giving speeches?
Are you going up with other politicians?
What are you doing?
- No, I'm basically
going to activist groups.
And in some towns we go through,
that might be 30 people meeting in a bar.
At other events, you know, I'm
speaking at events in Arizona
where, that's in a couple of
weeks time, where, you know,
500 have booked tickets already,
and I've no doubt it'll
be a lot bigger than that
on the day.
But I am meeting the people
who give of their time,
their love, their energy,
people that really care,
and I'm going out and meeting
them in their thousands
and trying to re-motivate them,
trying to get them out of.
And when I sit and talk to
them, they are very, very down.
Very, very down indeed.
So I'm trying through the Brexit example,
and also the immigration issue,
to explain to them that you know,
a huge victory may not be too far away.
So that's the main emphasis.
Obviously I'm doing media,
various other things like that.
But really, this is about
getting out with freedom works
and meeting these people
who did such a great job.
I mean, just look at the House,
you know, where the party picked up seats.
And you know, I've met
Congressmen and women who say,
"Look, we love this organization
"because when we need help, when we shout,
"people, keen people arrive."
So it is about motivation,
and it's also too,
I want to raise an issue which is,
most people in and around politics,
they think that the grassroots
bit doesn't really matter.
And it's the least
glamorous bit of politics.
But I know from all the races
that I've been involved in,
and particularly when we
got Brexit back on track,
I know that a good grassroots
campaign is the absolute key,
because remember this,
on the left side of the
debate here in America,
you've got the trade unions,
you've got many of the students,
they have an army on the ground.
And at the moment, I don't
believe the Republican Party
does have one of sufficient
scale and sufficient size.
So I'm trying to push that
argument that everybody can help.
It's no good just turning
up and clapping somebody.
You've actually, if you believe in this,
you've gotta commit that
you're gonna do something.
And it doesn't matter if you're 97
and sitting in a wheelchair,
you can still do something.
You can still make some phone calls.
There are still things
that everybody can do.
And if you really do
want to save your country
from hard left socialism,
sitting around and
complaining isn't the answer.
Positive attitude, energy, and action is.
- Do you think it's kind
of funny that you ended up,
you did the Brexit thing, and
now you're here doing this,
and it's like, there'll
probably be something else
that you'll be fighting for in 10 years.
You don't strike me as
someone that will ever retire.
- I wouldn't have thought
so for a moment, no, no.
I mean, I like campaigning,
and at the end of the day,
I think the most important thing
we can all do as human beings,
and as early as possible if we can,
find out what you're good at.
Find out the one thing in
life that you're good at
and pursue it.
And I'll be honest with you,
there are lots of things I'm terrible at,
lots of things I'm hopeless at.
But I've always, I like people,
I'm very gregarious, I'm very social,
as you mentioned earlier
on in the chat we've had,
and I love going out.
I love going out,
meeting groups of people.
And I think I can do my little bit,
perhaps to spread a
little bit of inspiration,
a little bit of optimism.
So no, I'm gonna go on fighting
for these Conservative causes
across the English speaking world.
And so I'll do stuff in
the UK, I'll do stuff here.
I can't wait to get back to Australia
to do more stuff down there.
As for New Zealand, I'm not
quite sure where we stand there,
given that they've now
basically sold their souls
to the Chinese Communist Party,
which should be a warning to all of us.
So no, I love this, I love
campaigning, I love life,
and yeah, I'm gonna keep on running.
- Well Nigel, I love this interview.
So I hope I can join you
on tour at some point
in the midst of this thing.
We're trying to coordinate
a couple of things,
but I think the message
that you're bringing
is exactly what Americans
need to hear right now.
It's kind of funny that it's coming
from somebody from the UK,
but we'll take it in this strange time,
so I wish you luck with everything.
- Well, thank you.
And remember this, culturally,
the UK and America have
never ever been closer.
You know, my kids watch
American television,
taxi drivers here talk to me
about Downton Abbey or The Crown.
NFL is now very popular in England.
Soccer's becoming popular here in the USA.
And just a final thought on this,
when Donald Trump was on tour,
you know, make America great again,
emphasizing those three
words, "Made in the USA".
Everything had to be American.
And as Air Force One
appeared on the horizon,
and the music started to play,
there was such a big feature
of the Trump rallies,
what music did we get?
Well, we got David Bowie, and
Elton John, and Phil Collins.
And actually, it's difficult
with popular music now to tell
whether it's British, or
whether it's American.
So perhaps a Brit coming
here, giving this message,
is not quite as strange as
people might first think.
- We'll take it, we'll take it.
Nigel Farage, thank you so much.
And we're gonna link to
everything right down below.
If you're looking for more honest
and thoughtful conversations
about international issues
instead of nonstop yelling,
check out our international playlist.
And if you wanna watch full interviews
on a variety of topics,
check out our full episode playlist,
they're all right over here.
And to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.